water mud fat and salt this is what
charlenon sent and her family are going
to be eating for the next few days
it is not just her she lives on four
dimensions one of the poorest areas in
Port-au-Prince
called Mud cookies they are a food of
Last Resort in Haiti and a symbol of the
country's deepening humanitarian crisis
we eat mud cookies because we are hungry
we don't have food it's salty and we eat
it we can drink water and we feel full
Haiti's capital and its slum areas like
City Soleil are now controlled by
violent gangs as a result access to food
is often impossible
the world food program says half of
Haiti's population is going hungry
humanitarian agents is working in Haiti
have had to adapt to the ongoing
violence
we have to prepare the meals outside so
here we're in Del Mar a communist
quarter prince it's not too far from
citas way we cook the food here the
volunteer cooks are here
they prepare big pots of rice and beans
we put that onto the truck the food the
hot food is driven down to see the
Soleil and distribute it immediately
because we cannot leave food stocks no
food no peace Haiti will never be at
peace as long as half of its population
requires a humanitarian assistance
the organization is also giving away
snack bars with protein for children
but Aid is not reaching everyone
all these people have been displaced by
gang related
children
it's just over a year old he's clearly
undernourished with skin problems
there's thousands of people who are
living like this in Haiti right now
is living in an improvised shelter in
the neighborhood of solino
she delivered her baby here two months
ago and says finding food has become a
daily challenge
they were shooting all over the
neighborhood everyone ran to save their
lives a priest gave us this place for
shelter most children here are not
eating every day
violence and hunger continue to spread
throughout Haiti and while the
International Community discusses
possible solutions those who live here
are clearly desperate for any help they
can get
Prince